the 10th anniversary of the European  Union's Big Bang enlargement into  Eastern Europe will be marked by the e  use General Affairs Council this month  the enlargement on may first 2004 taking  in eight Central and Eastern European  countries as well as Cyprus and Malta  was the e use biggest ever and so it  grow to 25 member states the council  will also make preparations for the  summit of EU leaders in June marking the  end of the Greek presidency that summit  will focus on immigration following the  tragedy of the Italian island of  Lampedusa last October when more than  300 people died after the boat trying to  bring them illegally into Europe sank  the leaders will also focus on economic  growth and jobs and discuss climate  change and energy policy